[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo
[Música]
ser inmigrante ubica en el imaginario
colectivo a las mujeres en una situación
de vulnerabilidad social sin embargo el
género no es sinónimo de victimización
no todas las puertas se cerraron para
mujeres que cruzan fronteras hoy los
invito a conocer dos ejemplos de mujeres
latinas e inmigrantes que son agentes de
desarrollo e integración
mariah trozas dominicana y llegó a eeuu
con tan sólo 15 años después de ser
abusada una experiencia traumática que
superó con los años y que le dio fuerzas
para ayudar a otros en su comunidad
ahora no sólo apoya psicológicamente a
mujeres que pasaron por lo mismo que
ella sino que también ofrece a la
comunidad hispana en nueva york' un
centro médico donde reciben atención
digna y económica la historia de nuestra
corresponsal mab en sala
carolina es uno de los 20.000 pacientes
de este centro médico vengo para una
cita que tengo programada para un test
de sangre llegó a eeuu hace dos años y
como mujer inmigrante con pocos recursos
pronto se dio cuenta de las dificultades
para acceder a un seguro médico aquí por
un dólar al día ha encontrado lo que
buscaba soy emigrante indocumentada
entonces aquí me siento muy tranquila
porque siempre vengo y siempre tengo mis
médicos que si tú es nomás la higiene y
la estética del lugar te puedes dar
cuenta que cumplen con las regulaciones
y eso es lo más importante y todo
gracias a ella
para muchos es símbolo de esperanza tras
25 años en el sector sanitario en el
2015 maría abrió este centro con su
socia para ayudar a la comunidad hispana
especialmente las personas
indocumentadas no hay muchas opciones
para estos pacientes poder ir a un
centro con donde van a recibir cuidados
médicos con dignidad y no tienen que
esperar meses para ver un especialista
por eso nosotros decidimos en este
centro a aumentar la calidad de los
servicios que nosotros iban a traer este
paciente 20 profesionales trabajan sin
descanso de lunes a viernes y ni
siquiera el kobe 19 ha podido con ellos
al principio de la pandemia cerraron sus
puertas por falta de mascarillas pero
tres semanas después volvieron más
fuertes que nunca para mí fue bien duro
porque si no venían a nuestro centro la
mayoría de las personas que eran
entiendo comentada no tenían muchas
opciones empezamos a hacer los exámenes
al final de marzo y estábamos haciendo
casi 150 exámenes o más diarios hasta
hoy hemos hecho más
de 7000 pruebas del coronavirus ayudar a
la comunidad hispana es el motor de su
vida maría es una mujer coraje que dejó
atrás una infancia traumática tras ser
abusada a los nueve años ahora cuenta su
historia en este libro con la esperanza
de que llegue a todas las mujeres que
como ella han elegido reescribir su vida
y de nueva york que vamos a perú en lima
una migrante venezolana reinventa su
vida limpiando puentes peatonales ella
no recibió un sueldo sin embargo
transformó una sucia y abandonada
infraestructura en un agradable lugar
que ha generado la admiración de muchos
peruanos nuestro corresponsal en lima
francisco zacarías estuvo con ella y nos
reporta esta historia
adiós ver y jiménez limpiar puentes le
permite mantener su hogar esta
venezolana llegó a perú hace más de dos
años y para agradecer la generosidad de
los transeúntes decidió reinvertir parte
del dinero en adornos ornamentales y yo
tenía que darle algo a perú de todo lo
que yo me daba en donde bien no tengo
que darle algo para que ellos se sientan
como que agradecido y empecé a éste a
colocar flor por flor y de acuerdo a lo
que yo me han colaborando le ha
colocando una cosa más ama como
agradecimiento hacia él y así esté
apático puente cobra vida las flores de
plástico que parecen reales y mariposas
de fantasía son el recordado que dios
mari con ayuda de su esposo mantienen
cada día el ambiente naturaleza que
inunda el lugar generó un interés de los
ciudadanos quienes también acuden al
puente para tomarse fotos está muy
hermoso está muy diferente
parece muy muy bonito que hagan este
tipo de cosas y llegaron personas ya
inteligentemente lo empezaron a hacer
mantenimiento todo bueno decorarlo se ve
bonito
da un ejemplo pese a estar así limpio y
la creatividad está las personas que
ponen a pensar el detalle y si nuestras
autoridades no han hecho esto bueno es
una llamada de atención para ellos que
pueden hacer muchísimo más rápido y
aquellos vive aquí dios marino es
conformista y ya está preparando un
decorado para navidad con algunos
detalles de su querida venezuela
y este amor es el encendido de la
navidad
entonces yo tomé esta idea y aquí vamos
a hacer el encendido de la navidad el
primero de diciembre con toda la
decoración creada por mí no es nada
comprado no yo estoy haciendo todo
diezmar y también disfruta de su
emprendimiento está contenta pronto
varios de sus compatriotas que le piden
asesoría replicarán su iniciativa en
otros lugares de lima
mariah y dios mari son dos ejemplos de
los cientos de historias de mujeres
latinas que aportan en la medida de sus
posibilidades a las comunidades que las
reciben y el dato de migración de la
semana según el último informe de
naciones unidas sobre las migraciones en
el mundo que detalla las cifras de
movilidad en 2019 de los 272 millones de
emigrantes internacionales el 48% de los
desarraigados fueron mujeres casi la
mitad de los que huyen en el mundo hasta
que inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan conectados con más información en
france 24 en france 24 punto com
[Música]